mais d'abord la lassitude voir la colère
d'une trentaine de foyers à Esvres sur
Indre cela fait maintenant un mois
qu'ils n'ont plus accès à Internet en
cause un câble orange sectionné lors
d'un chantier et depuis c'est le calme
plat chez ces particuliers qui doivent
apprendre à vivre sans télévision
téléphone et internet un casse-tête qui
se transforme en bras de fer avec
l'opérateur Florent Clavel
bon pas de téléphone
[Musique]
pas d'internet
ni internet ni téléphone Jacky et
victime d'une banale panne de réseau
mais qui s'avère vite être un handicap à
l'air du tout numérique on est
absolument coupé de toutes les
communications habituelles pour moi ce
qui est plus embêtant c'est la partie
justement internet qui nous prive de
tous les services de connexion
administratif banal enfin pas tout à
fait car cela fait déjà un mois que la
situation dure un mois que Jacky relance
l'opérateur Orange et agite sa pétition
pour faire pression mais toujours pas de
techniciens à l'horizon mais plus
l'impression d'être face à un vide les
gens qui sont sur les plateformes orange
sont au courant du problème mais non pas
absolument aucun moyen de d'intervenir
dessus la panne touche une trentaine de
foyers situés à la périphérie d'evres
sur Indre et notamment des personnes
âgées isolées en cause l'arrachage
accidentel lors de travaux d'un câble
adsl mal répertorié donc voici l'objet
de la discorde